hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich sitze mal wieder mit selfie
Sandra und rechts von mir sitzt Laser
Luca
nicht lachen
Challenge mit tik tok
737.000 eine Million Trillionen 799
oh
mein Gott
Topf nicht
[Musik]
hallo hallo
einfach nach Hause ich trete auf
irgendwas drauf einfach diese Kröte
Bruder einfach aus Versehen drauf
getreten Bruder
hey lebst du noch
ich finde Tiere nicht lustig warum keine
Ahnung du kannst mir egal welches Tier
wie die finde nicht lustig
ich glaube
Trash
inside
or ready out of trashiana
in dieser
Isabella machen
lernen Babbel
sehr gut Bruder
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
junge ich habe einfach Pizza mit diesem
Schinken hier bestellt da kommt einfach
so eine Vorhaut junge wer ist denn sowas
abgelaufen seit 2012 Pro Leute
[Musik]
das hat gar nichts damit zu tun einfach
17 Jahre alt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich verstehe das nicht dass sie dann
sagen soll Fuchs oder so
das heißt sie sieht sich als weibliche
Person
und warum dann
hörst doch ihr oder
was
ich das genauso kann wie die Robben
ich kotze
ja das geht raus an meinen siebte Klasse
deutscher er meinte ich werde es zu
nichts bringen oder auf der Straße
landen das habe ich nie gesagt das geht
raus an Dich blöder Pisser Junge
immer so sagen alle meine Lehrer haben
immer gesagt
auch gesagt ehrlich ja ich habe das noch
nie einen Lehrer zu ihm gesagt gehört
nicht mal weil mein übelsten wirklich
bruchkameraden die gar nichts konnten
hat auch nie Lehrer gesagt nichts
doch ja zu dir schon geworden nichts
[Musik]
es ist so gut nachgemacht
Peter Lustig
Hamburg
Abbruch nein hallo das sind meine
Kollegen und wir haben alles Talente
fangen einmal an also ich bin ab und zu
wie ein Pferd
ich kann wie Donald Duck machen diese
Ente danke
[Musik]
ja direkt
das war davor sagen was du denken ah nee
doch
Weinflaschen richtig lang
Weinflaschen
dicker was haben die auch für die die
locker richtig
[Musik]
sauber
das gleiche oh mein Gott
[Musik]
wird dich so zerlegen Bruder
and like to space and a little bit like
the
der ist so dumm ne er sagt der Geruch
einer Zahnpasta riecht nach Zahnpasta
danke
[Musik]
nein nein
[Applaus]